Bonjour à tous, je suis Frank Kim,
je suis instructeur de self defense depuis 2009
et je vais vous enseigner des méthodes simples pour vous sortir de situations de conflit.
Je serai assisté par Noël.
Donc là, imaginons que l’individu engage une frappe
destinée à atteindre les membres supérieurs.
Vous désaxez,
prenez le contrôle du poignet,
vous l’entrainez au sol.
Ça va?
Donc là imaginons que l’individu vous attaque par derrière,
il trahit votre confiance.
Vous neutralisez le bras d’attaque,
demi-tour pour faire face.
Donc là imaginons que quelqu’un
vous a emprunté de l’argent,
il vous a dit qu’il vous le rendrait au bout d’une semaine,
pourtant ça fait six mois que vous attendez votre pognon,
vous passez des coups de fil et rien, pas de réponse,
et sous prétexte que c’est votre beau-frère, faudrait rien dire.
Attaque-moi.
Non mais c’est n’importe quoi.
-Attaque-moi.
Mon fric putain!
Tu m’as pris pour une baltringue ou quoi?
Tu veux que je passe à la maison?
Tu veux que je passe chez toi?
Mon fric putain, merde!
Relève-toi.
Donc là, toujours votre beau-frère,
soit disant «Oh le pauvre, il a pas d’argent»,
vous allez sur son Facebook, le mec il s’est acheté la PlayStation.
Sans argent, le mec il s’est acheté la PlayStation.
C’était l’Xbox One.
Là, qu’est-ce que vous faites?
Vous lui mettez une claque, le mec vous a même pas attaqué.
Putain de …
...PlayStation.
Donc là imaginons que l’individu
est parti, il a foutu le camp, il est plus là.
Donc l’important c’est d’être bien sur ses appuis,
et surtout d’avoir deux copains qui vous l’attendent à la sortie du dojo pour vous le ramener.
Je vais te le rendre ton fric.
Donc là imaginez que votre beau-frère
a porté plainte pour coups et blessures.
Ok, calmez-vous Monsieur, calmez-vous.
-Vous laissez pas impressionner.
Pas de caméra.
-Tu filmes, tu filmes!
Ok, mains sur la tête!
Jamais, jamais les mains sur la tête justement …